all right it's here the star wars story
i've waited for for
life a quick shout out first this video
is brought to you by ag-1 by athletic
greens going to talk about that a little
later in the video but first we have a
star wars series the world not a series
first two episodes of a series to talk
about that's star wars inquisitor so
star wars inquisitor follows an
inquisitor known as third sister she's
searching for obi-wan kenobi trying to
weed him out and the show itself is
actually weirdly titled obi-wan kenobi i
say kind of ingest but only kind of in a
world where we should try to balance
sugar and spice what i liked about the
show two scenes in particular really
stood out one we kind of saw a glimpse
of in the trailer so we already knew
what was going to is when obi-wan is
talking to owen when the time comes he
must be trained like he changed his
father because in the original star wars
movie we saw that there was tension
between those two somewhere in their
past and we see a little more of it here
but now obi wan is off of tatooine so we
might not see any more i don't know and
the other scene of spoiler alert
i should tell you that we're gonna talk
about spoilers in the first two episodes
of obi-wan kenobi not gonna be a
play-by-play as usual but you know in
the last scene where riva is taunting
obi-wan and talking about darth vader
and anakin skywalker and obi-wan
ewen sells it you see the pain and
realization in this guy's eyes where
it's like these inquisitors are not the
emperor's inquisitors no this is his
former friend his old friend who's out
there killing jedi they work for him i'd
throw up he looked like he wanted to i
can't stress how important it was for
them to air the second episode along
with the first because if it just left
off where the first episode left off i'd
be like
okay
i guess i'll wait and binge it so
basically inquisitor riva knows that
obi-wan was friends with bail organa and
so she orchestrates this whole plot to
have bail organa's daughter leia
kidnapped to weed obi-wan out so obi-wan
goes and rescues her and she's like i
gotcha and that's the point of well the
show or at least the first two episodes
of the show which really does kind of
[ __ ] with the continuity there's
actually a few things in here that
messes with continuity but it messes
with the continuity of comment replies
that i get when i gripe about the fact
that in the original trilogy people
don't really remember jedi they're
almost mythical
20 years after the fact when they were
the generals of the clone army in this
all-encompassing galaxy-encompassing
civil war known as the clone wars i feel
like more people would remember them but
the argument is the empire was like all
right they've deleted information about
jedi you know they can control
information like that or they call it in
the empire fact-checking apparently not
very well because this lady kind of
sniffed out that obi-wan kenobi and bale
organa were friends because you see
alderaan and until jimmy smith's bail
organa shows up which i love seeing
jimmy smith as baylor again every time i
see him like even in rogue one i was
like oh [ __ ] all the alderaan stuff felt
weirdly out of place until leia being
kidnapped became the point of the show
at least the first two episodes and i
was like oh so that weirdly out of place
thing just kind of became the point fair
enough so bail organic goes to tatooine
goes to obi-wan which if inquisitor riva
followed bail organic ship she would
have found obi-wan could have saved us a
lot of filler well baylor again is
pretty much like obi-wan we're pals my
daughter who's the princess of
alderaan's been kidnapped could i amass
a royal guard to go find her could i
probably get a couple planets behind me
searching for her as well yes also i've
tracked their ship so we know exactly
where she is obi-wan goes to the scumbag
planet where some of the dumbest
decision making i've seen in star wars
history at least on screen took place
one of which stands out as this dude
who's faking being a jedi to basically
scam people out of money i could see
someone doing that when the clone wars
were going down sure also him even doing
this now shows that people do remember
jedi so the whole argument that they
don't but some years after the jedi were
declared terrorists this guy is like hey
i'm gonna fake being a jedi to make some
coin also i'm gonna do that in a city
where there's a clone trooper that's
like some years after 9 11 being like
i'm gonna fake being a terrorist because
i think i can make some quick cash also
in the same city jack bauer lives it
just doesn't seem smart now that this
dude who's faking being a jedi would
know that this homeless clone trooper
has programming in his brain to kill
jedi but it is kind of weird that this
homeless clone trooper who has
programming in his brain to kill jedi
isn't trying to kill the guy who's
trying to pretend to be a jedi also the
clone trooper is one of the coolest
parts of these first two episodes man
it's like the clone troopers were
disbanded i always think like what
happened to them so here's one of them
just holding out his helmet begging for
change there's no fight for him anymore
the empire's like yeah bye we use
stormtroopers now it was cool to see
also wasted opportunity i personally
think it would have been badass after
inquisitor riva sends out this apb
for obi-wan kenobi that clone trooper
should have been like
jedi dumped the change out of his helmet
put his helmet on and went to work
because good soldiers follow orders
that's what that clone trooper knows he
still has that programming in his head
the reason he's not out there trying to
kill jedi is because he doesn't think
there any jedi around the moment some
apb comes around town and says hey by
the way obi-wan kenobi find this jedi he
should have put the helmet on and gone
to work that would have been pretty
awesome in terms of continuity lore
breaking some things i mean there's an
argument for and against but i can't
help but see the four can't help to see
the fact it's like there are things that
happen in here that i just
i don't think it makes sense first of
which is third sister stabbing grand
inquisitor first of all grand inquisitor
should have deflected that lightsaber
and they should have gotten into a fight
at least but you know i mean the dude's
called grand inquisitor she probably
wouldn't live through it so maybe the
thought is like oh we brought darth maul
back i mean he got sliced in half and
fell down a pit it's pretty hard to live
through this dude just got stabbed guess
we can bring him back you keep killing
people and bringing him back it just
kind of negates the profound nature of
death in star wars so now obi-wan knows
anakin's alive at least in the physical
sense i mean vader's alive he's now it
looks like the series is gonna be like
all right
he wants to go find him which makes me
feel like this whole thing could have
been condensed into a movie i can't help
but see wasted time in an obi-wan series
because they wanted to build up an
inquisitor's storyline which an
inquisitor's story and inquisitor series
absolutely there's a place for that
isn't obi-wan series a place for that
not as they've executed it thus far so i
can't help but see it as
just some sort of conflicting waste of
time there is an order 66 scene as much
as i love me a good order 66 scene i
feel like they kind of jumped the gun
they should have had the order 66
flashback scene
episode three maybe four because it's
been over 15 years now since we last saw
ewan mcgregor's obi-wan kenobi the intro
scene to this series should have been
obi-wan kenobi doing something it should
have been set up for his character it's
his show as it stands the intro scene
the setup scene is the order 66 scene
for third sister this inquisitor riva
character i wonder if that order 66
scene's gonna explain how she knows that
anakin skywalker is darth vader people
aren't supposed to know that maybe when
she was running she saw anakin just
slaughtering jedi and maybe some of the
clone troopers were like lord vader
they're hiding over here and she's like
oh
put it all together when i was a kid
it's either that or darth vader when
he's in his
hyperbaric jizz bath is just like let me
tell you about my past like dad no even
then if she had any face time with vader
whatsoever i feel like he would sense
that he'd be like your thoughts betray
you you
know my backstory well you know what
that's not gonna work for me that was an
epic shot though but obi-wan was sitting
there and he was like anakin and it
snapped to darth vader in his
hyperbaric
but he's just there you hear the
breathing and i mean i liked that shot
when it was in star wars series fan film
as well i'm not saying they ripped it
off from star wars theory i'm just
saying if star wars theory who does have
a youtube channel dedicated to talking
star wars if he sees this episode in
that shot and he's like
did they just he would be forgiven for
thinking that you know that was part of
the conversation they were like we saw
that fan film we like the shot we're
totally gonna use it in the end what i
liked in these two episodes it's kind of
it's like their book ends we have one
thing over here near the beginning one
thing at the end other than ewan
mcgregor who always commits he's always
great but i liked uncle owen and i liked
when obi-wan kenobi found out that
anakin skywalker darth vader is very
much alive and out there in between's a
whole lot of filler which it's doing
exactly what i was afraid the series
would do bigger is always better he's
got a jam packet with a bunch of stuff
but what they took on
was a very personal story of one man's
tragedy the tragedy of his life his
legacy his friendship i don't think he
had to do this leia got kidnapped side
filler story in order to get obi-wan
kenobi to find out that darth vader is
alive and anakin is alive and he's out
there that is the point like if you
think oh to what end is this happening
like that is the point of all that
happening obi-wan could have heard it
from an inquisitor on tatooine either
directly or indirectly or i mean he is
on tatooine he could have taken a page
from his old friend anakin's book and
listened to all the traitors and star
pilots who come through there point is
he could have learned that darth vader
is out there and alive while he was on
tatooine i mean that could have been the
first 15 minutes of the show which
probably could be condensed into a movie
but we have four more episodes of the
show so i imagine there's just gonna be
a lot of filler getting to the meat of
what fans want but i am interested in
how they do the face to face of obi-wan
and darth vader i mean i'm more
interested in the dialogue i mean
obi-wan darth vader they're probably
gonna fight yeah but i am more
interested in the conversation between
the two leading up to that almost
inevitable fight and now with
sponsorship segments so epic it actually
made me grow my hair back and as
mentioned earlier in this video this
video is brought to you by ag-1 by
athletic greens which a couple months
ago became part of my every morning
daily routine and has remained so i love
it each scoop of aj once packed with
probiotics and vitamins which helps in
your daily physical health routine as
well as brain health just having it in
the morning personally helps me feel
perfectly balanced as all things should
be yourself one scoop of ag1 water ice
oatmeal banana put it in a blender blend
to perfection you have yourself a nice
morning shake to get your day started
power stance but also if you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten-free
you still have ag-1 so click the link
below and get yourself a year's supply
of vitamin d3k2 and 5 travel packs for
free with your first purchase and thank
you once again to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
alright so obi-wan kenobi episodes one
and two have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you